video has gone viral of a mom at a
Panera Bread drive-thru trying to order
her meal while the Panera Bread employee
on the other end refuses to take the
order so you are going to refuse to take
my order because my child was screaming
yes I have the right to do that if
you're more than welcome to come Insider
you can place an order online and we'll
make it for you and what is really like
you're going to not take my order yes
ma'am that is what I'm saying okay all
right well I do have this on video and I
will be emailing corporate because
that's just like completely rude we
can't even talk about the dispute until
we deal with the fact that this woman
went to a Panera breed drive-thru in the
first place like there is simply no good
reason there's no valid excuse to ever
go to a Panera breed drive-thru we can't
know for sure what was happening before
the video began we can't know how much
screaming the child was doing but I
think it's fair to assume that it was on
par with what we heard in the video like
it's a little Annoying and slightly
distracting but you can still do your
job